speaking of the the truth um here i want
to go to did you did you see that howard
what howard stern had said about this
supreme court decision yes i don't think
he's i i think he's i think that's
totally fine i think he's spot on here
um a lot of people don't like howard
stern for a lot of different reasons um
i i was always a fan of howard because
he is provocative um and he's
provocative in a way that makes you
think again kind of like a comedian
would make you think about an issue but
he really does get a uh
he gets straight to the point here and
the reason why we have the situation
that we have and if you're wondering out
there why the situation is what it is
just listen to howard here and he'll
kind of explain it this really isn't
rocket science i mean he puts it in so
many words because howard stern is good
with words right but this isn't rocket
science of why we're in the situation he
just has a fabulous way of describing it
let's listen abortion come out how women
vote for this agenda is beyond me how
you would how who the hell wants to
carry a baby that you do not want
and again the people who uh carry these
uh babies who don't want them don't
raise these kids and then we're stuck
with them society is stuck with them the
people who are anti-abortion they don't
give to charity they don't raise these
kids i don't know who they think is
going to raise them
but um you know
you saw men if men got pregnant it would
be a different story no man would want
to be raped and then have to carry his
rapists uh baby
uh i think i think that's probably one
of one of the best points that he makes
in this uh this little two-minute clip
here is that look if this was reversed
and men had the burden of the state
telling them what medical procedure they
can and cannot get and forcing them to
carry
uh a baby to term this this would be
completely different totally
we would not even be having this
discussion because this opinion would
not even exist the only reason why it
exists is because men want to [ __ ]
tell women what the [ __ ] they want to do
because that's the truth of the matter
that we have here is it is men in this
country weird ass [ __ ] freak ass men
wanting weirdos [ __ ] weirdos that
they are so concerned with a woman's
vagina why are you so concerned with a
woman's body you [ __ ] weirdo they are
very concerned with something that they
probably won't get that's right let's
just be honest about it right i mean i
mean man they're they're completely
obsessed with people's genitalia and
bathrooms it's the same [ __ ]
it's the same minority who want to ban
macbooks because it's crt it's the same
minority that want to tell lgbtq people
what the [ __ ] they can and can't do and
who they can love and who they can marry
and what they can identify as this is
really [ __ ] these are [ __ ] weirdos
they're fascist but they're weirdos and
howard stern has it right on the head
that there's no [ __ ] way that men in
this country would let some [ __ ]
weirdo ass men tell them what they could
and couldn't do about their own
pregnancy let me tell you that is one
[ __ ] thing that men would not
put up with this in this country and
women shouldn't either and us men should
not put up with [ __ ] men telling
women what to do either that's for
goddamn sure because they'll come for
you next and they're coming for women's
contraception that's the next step but
let's listen to what howard says how he
wraps it up in a bow here
um men we're ready to tear this country
down because we ask them to wear a mask
let alone have some baby they don't want
yeah but okay how did we get to this
point
the electoral college says and i guess
this was set up back in the good old
days
because they wanted everyone to have
some kind of representation but here's
what happened three million voters
were the majority who voted for hillary
clinton but they ended up with trump we
got a minority president
who held views that were the minority of
this country
so much so that he lost by three million
votes and he became president and then
he did the country of favor and found
the most radical supreme court justices
who all agreed
that abortion was now he alludes to it
here but he didn't find the most radical
uh the most radical supreme court
justice were bought and paid for and
placed on a list and donald trump was
forced that was the deal he made with
the devil was that he would pick the
supreme court justice from the
federalist society that's why all the
evangelical christians back this [ __ ]
grabbing three-time married [ __ ]
non-christian dave yeah they elected him
because he agreed to make sure that this
what we're going through right now what
happened i mean if anyone wants to get
mad at anyone people should be looking
to people like george conway all right i
think he's your friend you know he's
like oh who he's a never trumper no man
george conway is nobody's friend he will
at any moment turn his back on you and
then also simultaneously stab it but uh
he is you know huge i think he had a
tweet yesterday that was pushing
why this decision was was so correct
right it's ahead and saying that roe
versus wade had regressed the
advancement of of women's rights you
know which is insane because it's the
complete opposite and so george conway
you know one of the people the federal
society the one of the people like tony
said who are the are the you know not
going to say they're the puppeteers but
they are the people that are [ __ ]
pushing and and pain and and making sure
that
certain people are in power
they're lining those things up it's like
how do you think we got to where we are
right now it's because those people were
the ones who were funding it those are
the ones who were making the decision
right right and they just got pissed off
right they just got pissed off that it
didn't happen the way that they wanted
it to happen yeah and that cristo makes
a good point here heritage foundation
too yeah yeah mayo says you know just
like his wife kellyanne conway right
another
demon in uh human form
but he just asked just ask their
daughter just right yeah she was yeah oh
my god
but yeah
again you know what these groups are you
know privately funded right wing fascist
think tanks organizations
foundations whatever you want to call
them but they're the ones that are you
know i mean
the rest of dc is also funded in certain
ways but these are the people if you
want to look at who is the who is
responsible for pushing this type of
this uh type of opinion that has been
dissented you know um you got to look at
george conway kellyanne conway the
heritage foundation the federal society
like these are the people
that are the ones that are
pushing the buttons someone on twitch
here says the [ __ ] keeper you
you shouldn't call kellyanne conway the
crypt how dare you on my show that is an
insult to the [ __ ] keeper that is an
insult that's right the crypt keeper
should be offended by what you just said
let's listen to what uh the rest of
howard stern's argument here of the
scotus draft decision wrong they've been
on some sort of a secret list that not
so secret list
so we ended up with this scenario
and we also ended up with it when uh
again you know uh obama didn't get to
pick a supreme court justice so okay so
now we have a minority viewpoint in this
country running the country if it was
the majority viewpoint all right you put
up with it but it's the minority
viewpoint now how much more are we going
to take
how much more of this [ __ ]
that some hillbilly in south dakota gets
a more important vote because he lives
in south dakota now that is a really a
really good point and what he's alluding
to there is the way that we elect the
president is that the the people in
south dakota are in the 2016 election
were afforded way more sway with their
vote than everyone else because it is
true that we get one person one vote in
this country but because of how our uh
our republic works and the presidential
election works especially um there is
more weight
for people in
uh areas where
there is less votes um where there's a
higher population now of course like the
state of new york and the state of
california receive more electoral votes
for the college but
um that still doesn't matter when you're
talking about if you put together the
right states that someone can lose by
three million votes and still become
president yeah now a lot of people want
to abolish uh that part of our election
system and actually i think the easiest
way is to not abolish it i think the
easiest way is to
um there is a project out there that is
trying to get states to pass their law
to where their state
actually gives their votes for the
college to the majority vote in their
state and as long as we get enough
states to do that the the popular vote
in the country should be right who the
president actually becomes rather
whether it republican democrat or
otherwise if we that's how it should be
right it makes total sense right like
you wouldn't just default and say all
right uh yeah we're gonna go with the
electoral college if you don't make the
popular vote then you know in the
popular vote but it's like wait wouldn't
that be the majority of people those are
the people who that is the majority of
the population of the united states who
said hey
uh we want this person to be in power we
have we have put our voice on the ballot
and our vote has gone to this person and
then what basically what our electoral
college system says is yeah yeah that's
that's nice that you decided that but
we're gonna go a different way right
like you're you know you're you're just
throwing throwing these people saying
that like oh everyone has a voice and
everyone has the right to vote and and
you want to make your you want to make
your voice your vote you know
uh established and heard right but this
is one of those moments where you look
at he's like yeah we'll [ __ ] those votes
right right well chris chris points out
chris from youtube points out a good
point here uh we need to do ranked
choice voting as well uh some states do
rank choice voting like maine does
ranked choice voting and some other
things and if you guys don't know what
ranked choice voting is go go google it
rank choice voting um it's a very unique
way to make sure that you rank your
candidates so in other words if there's
four candidates on the ballot or there's
six candidates on the ballot you know it
gets rid of this whole third party
[ __ ] argument um we really can toss
that [ __ ] to the side if we get to
ranked choice voting in some of these
dates but amanda i'm gonna push back a
little bit she says abolish the
electoral college i think there's a way
to actually circumvent the electoral
college in our laws without having to i
think abolishing it is a lot tougher
than actually getting states to say
we are going to give our electoral votes
to the majority of the vote in our state
if this because the state can decide
that the state can pass that law to do
that it is constitutional so there's a
constitutional way to make sure
in this country enough states have to
decide to do that and i i believe it's
only like three or four states away is
kind of the the math so wait wait are
you saying that
we should support states rights
well you know i think i think what we
should do is if the state has the right
to choose how they afford their
electoral college votes then we should
do that but when it comes to someone's
liberty when it comes to someone's
liberty because you get the vote now
they the state does not have the right
to keep you from voting right the state
does not keep you have the right despite
the fact that republicans try to do that
right well i mean i mean i talked about
the 19th amendment yesterday do you know
what the 19th amendment is
the exact wording no no no the 19th
amendment is the amendment that afforded
women the right to vote right yeah yeah
and i believe suffrage 1920 correct
correct and 22 was it 22. no it's not
1919 1920 i believe it was ratified in
1920 so it became official right exactly
it was passed in 1919 then ratified but
about a year later i believe once the
states ratified it but here we are
almost 100 years over 100 years later
and i'm telling you the next thing is
contraception and then they're going to
come after the women's vote and
everyone's like oh they can't they can't
because of the 19th amendment they go oh
they go after
black people's vote all the time people
of color's vote is at jeopardy all the
time
with these [ __ ] gqp fascists just
because you're white doesn't mean you're
safe just because they can't just say
women can't vote doesn't mean they won't
try to take away your ability to that is
such [ __ ] they are coming after your
right to vote and the reason why i know
they're coming after women's right to
vote is because the the the absolute
uproar you're going to see about this
decision yeah on roe v wade you're going
to see an uproar and they're going to
figure out that holy [ __ ] are our
our constituency is at risk right so we
got to make sure to pare down our
constituencies
the men are the men are speaking the men
are voting exactly right please
that's right let us let let us finish go
back to the kitchen simmer down simmer
down
go make me a sandwich that's what they
want right don't vote don't speak out
don't protest just go back into the
kitchen
take a little drug to make you calm
and i'll see you at dinner right keep
that aspirin between your legs and you
know and when you do have an abortion
[ __ ] you right and let's hear what
howard says here about about the
unwanted babies this is this is a great
dismount here for this clip let's hear
what he has to say about what we should
do with all all the unwanted babies um
that these fascists want to want to have
in our country
uh let me tell you something here's what
i say all unwanted children should be
allowed to live at the supreme court
building with those justices and they
should raise every one of those babies
that crackpot clarence thomas and that
wife and all of them they can raise
these babies that they want that's right
and and i i don't i i think that maybe
uh a supreme court uh
nursery is not a bad idea i mean if
they're gonna pass this law maybe we
should put it on them yeah i mean for
the same people that are like we gotta
protect the children we gotta we gotta
keep them safe we gotta make sure that
they're not being trafficked it's like
all right well uh i don't see you
adopting
you know oh pro-life pro-life i don't
see you giving them the resources or or
the money or or the organization or or
the programs to make sure that a single
parent a mother that you forced to have
a child get the actual support that she
needs because at the end of the day
that's what's happening right they look
at this and they say oh you know what
you have to have the baby you're like
okay cool fine you forced me to have the
baby right despite the fact that i want
to you made me have the baby are you
gonna give me the proper resources to
help me prepare the home
to give me the the uh you know the the
tools
to raise this child right the funds
to help raise them so i don't find
myself in crushing debt outside of the
fact that i just you know went to school
and now i'm already in crushing debt but
now like okay i gotta raise another life
on top of my own and make sure i care
for it will you give me the funds will
you will you point me to the right
program and an organization that will
help me with this and they're like oh
you know what actually we just closed
down the most uh uh the most recent
planned parenthood that was closest to
you right yeah you're like okay well
you're gonna you have another place that
i can go no actually the next one's uh
two states over right and you're like
well
what do i do
and then like oh well go get [ __ ] go
get bent go get bent yeah right oh yeah
and when you have the baby when you have
the baby that baby can get bent too
we're not gonna help right
speaking speaking of the supreme court
and the lying lying [ __ ] fascist
bought and paid for supreme court
justices did you see the video that
might just touch
uh but i just say lying gop it's it's
trending